it was so memorable because it was like
a revenge thing right the guys bashed up
my car because oh [ __ ] yeah man um one
of these guides
he's his girlfriend at the time I did
her favor something happened I forgot
what it was I think I helped her out
through a problem and then as a nice
gesture she made cookies for me the next
day and he saw that and he got [ __ ]
jealous right so he went on aim one
night and then he was like hey like I'm
stranded
he had the password to her account so he
was like hey I'm stranded I need help
oh he set you up yeah so I was like okay
where are you at and I'm like [ __ ] well
I guess I could take my mom's car and
help pick you up and then drop you off
right and then um I was like well I was
friends with their older brother - I was
like where's your older brother at why
can't he do it yeah she's like oh well
he's not in town right now and it but
this is like this party's weird like I
don't know how I got myself in here and
I was like you know what's so funny in
that situation as he's typing this out
and you're writing to this this girl
right different ways for you not to do
it you wouldn't think that he would
think oh maybe he's not trying to [ __ ]
this guy
yes I was like all right [ __ ] it you
know I'll go I'll come pick you up and
then so like I pulled up to the driveway
and then I turned off my car like an
idiot there's no music there's no sound
so I'm like I didn't get out of the car
yeah and then so I think I think I
texted her or something at the time but
while I was waiting in the car a bunch
of dudes with masks rolled up they
bashed my windows oh and all this [ __ ] I
was trying to turn the car on and then
like I don't know like I guess the car
wouldn't turn on because maybe I was a
little [ __ ] nightmare yeah cuz I was
panicked so I wasn't so I just kept
going - did you do it like right and I
wanted to run these guys over or
something I just wanted to drive off and
when they broke through the windows
they stuck their hands in with pepper
spray and they maced me
oh yeah and in and in so they just kept
cracking the car and then they all like
scattered like ants
so nobody pulled me out of the car
damaged me they just pretty much like
assaulted my car yeah and then so I was
like covered in pepper spray I didn't
know at the time but I was going home
and I just I just [ __ ] ran all the
red lights and and like Oh before that I
try to chase them down and they hop some
fences and I try to get to where their
car was because I was just gonna crash
my car into there to stop em and [ __ ]
yeah yeah but then they just bounced off
so I drove away and then basically I got
home my mom was like what the [ __ ]
happened and my mom had a drive to the
to the what do you call it the like our
auto manufacturer we called mechanic
mechanic yeah yeah which by the way is a
legendary drifter oh yeah he's a legend
[ __ ] it he's a and his son is my friend
too Kangoo she oh yeah [ __ ] dude a were
shocked they were like what happened and
I'm like man some gangsters just bashed
my car you know yeah and anyways so so
yeah my mom had to go through that and
that's when I recognized I thought I had
glass in my eyes and I was at home and I
was like trying to wash out the pepper
spray but it's crazy like during the
dren 'el in the pepper spray doesn't
really [ __ ] with you Oh like it just
makes you cry a lot and you're blinking
a lot but I feel like pepper spray might
not be the strongest thing to do like
when you want to get away from people
yeah but anyways so that that happened
and then I started investigating who it
was I had a hunch it was her ex but who
were the other guys you know and in so
her ex were or I guess what she told me
was they were going through a rough time
they weren't there they weren't actually
a couple anymore or something but he
still had her password and she totally
forgot about that oh yeah so he um he
was military so I guess he conveniently
planned this so he goes off to his like
base or whatever yeah so he left for
that
and then um so I was like well if I
can't get him I'm gonna get all of his
friends oh and I started figuring out
one by one who they were and like
there's been some times when I [ __ ] a
lot of them up one of the guys actually
that I found out I talked him at a
barber shop and I started getting
haircuts from him just to [ __ ] with his
head yeah and then I would have him I
would ask for him specifically to cut my
hair Oh Shannon I would have him cut my
hair and I'd have conversations with him
as if I didn't know anything yeah and
then um one day he said hey Joe I was
like well I just want you to know that
I'm sorry for what happened but I wasn't
there that night oh [ __ ]
so he was I think he felt weird about it
yeah and I was like okay I was like um
do you know who was it was yeah I don't
hang out with those guys anymore but he
told me the names I was like okay cool
cuz he was really close to those guys
yeah so I was really close to just like
basically [ __ ] with them for a little
bit and then one day like maybe during
his lunch and it was another time when
um one of his other buddies were boldly
laughing at me
so me and my buddy oh [ __ ] that makes
you mad yeah we were we were so we were
so we were at a corner at a stoplight by
by in and out and then he pulled up next
to me this this [ __ ] is like a spoiled
rich kid he had a BMW in high school and
you know he was always looked like a
wannabe gangster right so I drove up and
then he pulled up next to me and he
started laughing and smiling and I was
like oh there's no [ __ ] way he wasn't
a part of him yeah little did he know
next to me was one of my most hot-headed
violent friends and as soon as I looked
at him and he started laughing at me and
I said that's him my friend immediately
opened the door and then his door and he
started kicking him in there and that
guy's girlfriend was like stop
okay so I put my car in the ebrake I
[ __ ] did one of those Tony Jaa slide
slide over the [ __ ] hood things well
it probably looked like a more roll and
then we started beating his ass like in
the middle of the street because he
probably didn't expect us to course
that's what he was laughing yeah and
then um that was one that was one
incident right so one by one we were
starting to knock out these guys and
then the the thing was I never got the
ex he just disappeared at the face of
the this earth yeah and in one day so me
and my bar were me barred and a couple
of our buddies like they know this story
a lot of people knew what happened to me
yeah right
and then cuz I was like struck with
revenge like I was like this was this
happened right around high school 17 18
so I probably held this anger up until
my early 20s yeah and by that time like
me and Bart we were all a part of a
Fight Club like we went we that's when
we first met like we did MMA yeah and
then I'm funny story those guys they
love fighting but they're also very
honorable people and they never joined a
gang or anything like that there's
military guys they're very violent guys
right so those guys as in Bart and his
friends so they created this crew called
the peacekeepers that sounds like some
[ __ ] Bart would do is they're so stupid
so Dave a side story they would go to
frat parties and then like they would be
the unofficial security and if any fight
broke out they would [ __ ] up both of got
both of the guys that were fighting
there's a lot of they wanted an excuse
to fight but not feel guilty about it
they were so stupid yeah they were like
oh we're fighting for justice so like
they fight like guys don't fight though
don't run into fight they'll go to house
parties with gangs and then like still
start fights with them but they're like
we're not a gang though we're trying to
set the record straight like you guys
are [ __ ] stupid dude
I believe that I used to think you guys
are so cool man I'm like yeah that's a
different way to look at it I mean
you're 18 19 years [ __ ] dumb right
yeah yeah we're not a gang we're just
looking for other people to fight so you
[ __ ] everybody better fighting for
justice you know to me so I'm so stupid
I don't know like we're not a gang or a
[ __ ] security group you know like
stupid you know what I mean that's one
of the reasons why Bauer got so buff is
do was they got into a fight at a club
there I guess it was their peacekeeper
crew or whatever but it was this big-ass
Y huge right and um you know a couple of
scrawny ass Asian guys like they were
landing hits nothing was affecting this
dude oh nothing and then like you know I
think that really like bruised his ego
or like bruises like confidence and he
was like [ __ ] dude like I really got to
get strong cuz like he's like I could
land these hits but if the other guy's
stronger there's no way yeah yeah yeah
and then so he started working out but
yeah like so I already had this group
right like I wasn't a part of this group
I just like at that age like I didn't
have my gang with me I left that life I
started going to college actually you
know some of the guys in Bart's group
were were very helpful in that yeah like
like they were never they you know they
they got out of boot camp they're
military guys they were like kind of
showing me that there is a better way to
like live like amongst the world you
know yeah so I was like oh these guys
are dope like they're you know they're
down for their [ __ ] but they don't have
to be a part of anything and then they
want to elevate themselves go to college
and [ __ ] like that so I really like the
guys and and so but they were down for
me like they would fight for me all that
stuff so they were like and if anytime
we see these guys man we got your back
or whatever and in all the other
previous rivalries that I had like if I
had beef because it was gang-related I
didn't care anymore because to me it was
like sure like you know they might have
shot so-and-so or whatever like but I
thought that was
like not a legitimate reason and I never
had hate yeah I never cared to me it was
like okay it was a gang rivalry and it
started over stupid [ __ ] a lot of the
times it's it started because somebody
in my group was a dumb hothead and he
just wanted to start stuff yeah and we
got caught up in it
but I I never cared so I was like
whatever if I see a guy that was
supposed to be a rival or whatever like
I'll just be like [ __ ] it if they want
to but I'm not gonna start anything and
I don't have any hate toward that yeah
these guys I took it personal it was
personals [ __ ] right yes I mean I don't
know I just couldn't let it go and then
so we were at this bar and then um one
of the buddies was like hey he's in the
bathroom oh [ __ ] it was what he want to
do and then I looked at him like I was
like [ __ ] dude let me let me have some
time with him just me and him in the
bathroom like you guys go to the door
like hold it hold it down for me yeah
right so I go in this guy's washing his
hands the guy that laughed at me mm-hmm
at on the street right he's actually
like like a little bit taller and and
just I don't know but I knew I could
[ __ ] his ass up yeah so I went in and
then um um I think Bart was at the door
and another buddy of mine went into the
stall or something like that no no
actually it was just me and then okay so
it was me first and then Bart in another
guy at the door and then when I went in
there I didn't know that that guy's
buddy was taking a piss like in the in
the in a toilet side yeah so he was
washing his hands and I came in and also
like remember me [ __ ]
and then he looked up and then as soon
as he looked up he kind of like threw
his hands up so when he did is like
little gangster throwing hands up like
that I [ __ ] 300 kicked him in the
stomach oh [ __ ] and then and then we
just started like going at it right like
just throwing fists and then I feel this
foam from the back of my head so I guess
one of his buddies oh [ __ ] I mean they
he was in the bathroom too yeah so I
went down and then
as I was getting up both of them were on
me kicking me punching me so like I was
it somehow turned around where I was by
the like papers paper or towel
dispensers yeah and then like I'm
covering up and then like there's all
this commotion and that's when Barton
and my other buddy opened the door they
come around they pull the guys off of me
and they started launching right yeah
and here's the thing the guy that was
really bold and acting tough when the
table's turned around he started
screaming for help oh my god after he
jumped with you guys yeah dude so he was
like hell right and then um my other
buddy was outside coming in and and he
was like oh you need help and then he
says yeah there's guys and he just
started whaling in his [ __ ] face oh
[ __ ] he's like oh you need help and then
he grabbed him by the back in his holy
peace yes and then umm so yeah yeah and
the funny thing is my other friend was
kind of buzzing during the time and yeah
I mean a [ __ ] face thinking that I
was one of them oh my god instead of a
[ __ ]
so what right when he kicked me the
guy's got away yeah and then everybody
got away and it happened so fast and
then I got up in my um I knew I [ __ ]
got him in the face pretty hard because
my my ring finger on my right hand was
like oh [ __ ]
it was dislocated yeah that's the first
time I need someone so hard that it
dislocated right yeah I was like all
[ __ ] got him I must have got him good
right yeah but it'd knock nobody out so
I was like [ __ ] so then at this point
we're like oh [ __ ] let's go catch him in
the parking lot so we all ran and then
this is when like the security guard Hey
like all this commotion was happening
and in it was like a movie where we just
went through the kitchen and then it's
like we ran through the kitchen and
while I'm running I'm like up here like
putting it back into place cuz I was
like this my finger was like this and
I'm like oh [ __ ] and I put it back into
place and I ran out and then all of us
got into the parking lot when we got
there these guys love bashing cars man
[ __ ] cowards they had all their
weapons out they had all their weapons
out in there
walking toward they knew which one of
our cars were and they were walking
toward idols are you guys gonna [ __ ]
bash our cars like a little [ __ ] we're
all right here let's go and then they
had weapons yeah they didn't want to
attack us with their little weapons and
in these Samoan security guards came out
and in there